I tweeted one time that Kool-Aid ain't
but flavored City water and
were Furious that's when I
learned about like you started talking
about food and all that
you just insulted in childhood because
they did Grandmama gave them Kool-Aid
they made it together and it's not the
Kool-Aid that you miss it's the warm hug
and bosom of your grandma I never got
Grandma tips man all my grandmas were
dead and their tits were dead so I never
got that
you know what I thought about that
just to get that feeling that Muslim you
know yeah
my fondest memory of my memory of my
grandmother you should say your
finalists mindful my best memory you say
your best memory dude this guy is crazy
the most
grandest remember it's the grandest
memory
right this is the problem Roy
[Laughter]